a massive fire is still burning in
southern Texas after an explosion at a
chemical plant a second blast rattled
the city of Port Neches yesterday
afternoon the initial explosion hit
early yesterday morning and was felt up
to 30 miles away tens of thousands of
people have been told to evacuate Omar
Villafranca is in Texas with a look at
the devastation a wall of flames erupted
from the tpc plant in Port Neches Texas
just hours after a massive blast tore
through the refinery early Wednesday
morning the new explosion forced a
mandatory evacuation of about 60,000
people within a four-mile radius of the
plant putting many residents
Thanksgiving plans on hold I made in the
freezer ready to cook I had a turkey in
the oven just lit up the whole entire
sky hadn't seen anything like that
before the first blast happened just
after midnight in an area of the plant
that produces a highly flammable
chemical used to make synthetic rubber
and other products officials say it was
felt up to 30 miles away and blew out
windows and doors of nearby homes three
workers were hurt during the explosion
all have been treated and released state
authorities say a series of smaller
explosions occurred throughout the day
it puts a lot of fear and a lot of
families because their husbands and
wives and children work in these
refineries Texas has already seen
massive fires in at least five chemical
plants this year in April a fire at a
plant in Crosby just northeast of
Houston killed one person and seriously
injured two a loss of power at the plant
is preventing investigators from
estimating how long the fire will last
it's horrific when you realize what
force took the front door and put it in
your living room you know we're thankful
we're all safe we have a lot to be
thankful for this Thanksgiving for CBS
this morning I'm Omar Villafranca